how much better is the new 16-inch m1
pro macbook compared to the previous
intel 16-inch that it directly replaces
well today we will find out because we
are going to test everything from the
new displays the speakers the webcam to
performance overheating graphics and cpu
benchmarks and real world tests like
xcode logic blender along with photo and
video editing and more but before we get
into it i have to remind you guys that
we are giving away a 2500
m1 pro macbook pro to one of you guys no
matter where you are in the world i will
pay for shipping i will pay for whatever
import taxes we're gonna hook you up all
you have to do is make sure you're
subscribed and comment
on our videos with this launch week
we're gonna choose one of the videos and
then one comments are in those videos so
make sure you guys keep coming back and
commenting for your chance to win now
i'm also extremely excited because today
we are doing a battery life test both of
these are at a hundred percent i'm going
to unplug them right now and as we're
going through all of these tests we'll
see what kind of a difference we get in
terms of battery life with this new 16
inch in the real world now i'm gonna go
ahead and shut both of these down i know
i shouldn't press the button but i'm
doing it and we're gonna start out with
the exterior differences now if you guys
look size wise they are not that
different let me overlay the older
16-inch oh wow
i actually was not expecting this so the
new 16-inch is actually slightly deeper
but it is shorter is it mievidine what
do you see that
let's flip these this way i was not
expecting it to be slightly
uh shorter yeah look at that
so this is crazy that the footprint is
actually overall smaller for the new
16-inch but what about the thickness
let's set these side by side and bam
look at that you could see
how much thicker the new 16 inch is
compared to the previous one i actually
did the math and it's like nine percent
thicker but with that said the new feet
are actually a little bit taller so if
we set them on the backs we could see
that the difference isn't as big when
you're looking this way so the
difference isn't as big if we're looking
at the thickest portion here but of
course the 16 inch is tapered which
makes it look slimmer at the edges so
the new 16 inch definitely looks chunky
but i have to say i do like the new
retro design and that also allows for
more stuff to be fit inside of it now
let's go ahead and quickly compare the
ports on the left side we have the same
two thunderbolt ports this time it's
thunderbolt 4 but we also have magsafe
now and we have the headphone jack which
moved from the right side and it's more
convenient there on the right hand side
we have another thunderbolt port instead
of two and we have an hdmi port finally
and then once again we have an sd card
reader that supports speeds of up to 250
megabytes per second now here's
something that almost nobody knows with
a new 16-inch even though we only have
three thunderbolt ports each one of them
gets its own controller but in the past
each side each two ports had to share a
controller what this means is that these
three ports on the new inch they're
almost like six ports if you're daisy
chaining them because you don't get any
slow downs and this is also why the new
16 inch macbook pro can support up to
three 6k pro display xdrs instead of two
and along with that we also have that
hdmi for another 4k display now check
this out look how much larger that
cutout for the vents is on the back of
the new 16 inch it's not from the bottom
which means that if you have it on your
lap or a blanket the chance of it
getting blocked is much smaller and with
that if you're operating this in
clamshell mode and you're plugging into
display you're gonna have much better
airflow now with that if we compare the
vents on the sides the new 16-inch has
vents that are much larger and deeper
and wider so even though a little bit
shorter they're gonna support a lot more
airflow now with all of those vents
including the new central one i have to
pull out the ifixit kit you guys know
how we do here at max tech we want to
see what does the cooling look like on
the inside and what did apple change now
i want to remind you that this 16 inch
has the m1 pro chip but we bought eight
macbooks we already have four of them in
we're getting four more this week so i'm
excited to see how the cooling system
compares for the m1 max ship that has 32
graphics cores now with that we have a
ton of videos coming out we're going to
answer all of your guys's questions for
example 16 gigs versus 32 gigs on the m1
pros or 32 versus 64 on the m1 max also
the bin versus unbend 14 inch and
thermal throttling with the 14 inch
versus the 16 inch with m1 max chips so
guys make sure you're checking out our
videos every morning we post another
video come back and with that don't
forget to comment and be subscribed if
you guys want to win one of these
macbook pros all right guys this is
exciting let's take a look
bam look at that
look how much larger these casings are
for the fan on the 14-inch they weren't
that much bigger but here that is a
massive difference all right wow looking
at this is bringing out a lot more
questions than i thought of previously
vadim look at this you see this heatsink
right here do you see how the heat pipe
goes over the actual little fins there
look how much thicker that is over here
they stick out a ton and then with that
we see that we have one cpu block that
covers the m1 pro chip that has cpu and
graphics compared to two and of course
we have these larger fans so we'll see
with our thermal test i'm excited check
that out but with that look at these ssd
chips this 16 inch has two ssd chips for
the 512 model and then two empty slots
right here just like the 14 inch the new
14 inch macbook but the 16 inch has four
chips right here and then another chip
on this side and then three extra spots
if you get larger capacities now that
has me wondering what is the ssd speed
going to be on this 512 model compared
to my 14 inch 512 model and why is there
another chip usually it's linear about
128 gigabytes per chip is that extra
just for long-term reliability if you
guys know let me know down below now
with that check out these speaker
enclosures and subwoofers first they are
larger but second the actual speaker
enclosure is huge it doesn't have to
taper down and be small because of that
curved edge design it is much larger
overall so i'm excited to test out the
speakers and now we have these opened up
right here and the first thing that you
notice is that notch it is ugly you
definitely see it but of course if you
open something up in full screen it goes
away so there's no distractions and for
movies and all that sort of stuff you
will not see it it just gives us that
extra space and with that we get slimmer
bezels on the side slightly slimmer and
a lot slimmer on the top at the bottom
our macbook pro logo is now gone and
then looking lower the touch bar is also
gone now i didn't really like the touch
bar there's only a couple uses that
there was nice for now we have these
large full-size function keys and this
massive escape key the keyboard feel is
identical they have not changed that
both of these are excellent but we have
that new double anodized black finish
which looks good the track pads are also
identical and the last difference is the
speakers if you guys can notice that the
chassis isn't as wide we have less holes
here but with that said let's go ahead
and compare how the new system the apple
really advertised with better bass
actually sounds in the real world
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down below is this a big difference well
to my ears i know that the 16 inch
already sounded amazing it beat out
every windows laptop it had nice deep
bass from that six speaker system but
apple managed to make it even better
they improved the subwoofers they said
that they move like 80 more air and you
can hear the difference the bass is
lower it's deeper the mid sound
fantastic overall the sound sounds more
balanced and it's almost like having a
dedicated sub even though this one has
subs maybe going from like a 10 inch or
8 inch to a 12 inch
it's a pretty good improvement and the
speakers sound amazing on the new 16
inch and now let's compare the webcams
and microphones this is the intel 16
inch macbook pro with its 720p webcam
and its studio quality microphones and
this is the new 16-inch macbook pro with
apple's 1080p camera and the new f 2.0
lens which improves the low light
performance let me know if you guys
notice any differences in terms of
microphone quality and how much better
the video looks and now let's get into
the displays where we have a ton of
differences with the new xdr mini led
display first off it's almost 4k
resolution we have 30 more pixels than
with the previous 16 inch it's also a
pro motion display meaning it goes up to
120 hertz but it can actually slow down
to 24 hertz to match video content and
save battery it can also reach up to a
thousand it's sustained and 1600 peak
which i'll show you but in real world
use without hdr content it's limited to
500 so it should be the same but both
the 16-inch and the new 14-inch are
actually slightly brighter than the
models they replace and when we turn on
some hdr content i mean you guys can see
the difference you're not seeing the
full difference because it's not hdr
video but the highlights pop like crazy
the sun is popping like crazy well at
the same time we have better contrast so
all the shadows have more contrast the
detail looks better
it is just such a big difference what
display really looks amazing is when
you're watching movies especially in the
dark the mini led has such good contrast
the blacks look almost like oled levels
and of course the highlights also pop
for hdr instead of being pretty flat
with poor contrast in the black bars
when you're watching a widescreen movie
wow look at that guys that is a massive
difference with the sky now yes there
can be some blooming if you're running
hdr and you have super bright objects on
a black background but with the lcd
display and the old 16 inch you get
blooming everywhere because of that
single backlight but in real world use
this is extremely rare and if you have
the lights turned on you never see any
blooming and now let's get into
performance i want to start out by
seeing do those five ssd chips compared
to two really make a big difference
let's go ahead and hit start here i let
this run a couple times to get the
fastest speeds on both and look at this
we have 2500 read and write on the intel
16 inch and 4500 right and
5132 read with the new m1 pro 16 inch
now what's interesting is this is a 512
both of these are but our 14 inch 512
was in the 4 thousands for the read
speed so that different chip
configuration is definitely helping and
i'm really curious how much uh ssd do
you have to buy to reach that full 7.4
gigabytes maybe we'll find out in the
future and now let's test out the cpu
performance with geekbench i'm
interested because this is the unbinned
version the 16 inch doesn't have that so
we have eight performance cores here
compared to six cores plus six extra
threads um with the intel system this
one has that i7 2.6 gigahertz we're
using the same operating system let's go
ahead and run this all right bam we have
a result guys and what the difference
does one year make actually apple
silicon big so single core we have about
65 faster performance this makes
everything extremely snappy for simple
tasks but multi-core apple wasn't
messing around they're like we're not
even gonna double the performance we're
gonna give you pretty much 2.25 times
the performance for the same model that
is being replaced that is incredible and
now let's compare the graphics we have
the 16 core m1 pro graphics chip here
compared to amd's
5300 m let's go ahead and run this and
here we go we have 41 000 on the new
16-inch compared to 24 000 but as you
guys may have heard in yesterday's video
the performance isn't properly ramping
up with these m1 pro chips so here we
have a 69 increase in performance but we
will see what we actually get in the
real world and now we're gonna do a
gaming benchmark that's optimized for
metal to see the true differences i'm
running the off-screen test so the
resolution isn't changing anything and
i'm testing something else how much
wattage the gpus take we will find out
as we are finished up with this test so
let's hit start all right guys the test
is done and before i show you guys the
scores check out how much power the
intel and amd system uses so to run that
test our 5300m used
54.39 watts consistently they're almost
55 watts but on the m1 pro with the 16
core graphics it used
21.7 watts so basically the amd graphics
card or graphics chip uses two and a
half times more power to do this task
now what is the result that that power
usage gives you well in this test it got
88 frames per second for the amd system
and our m1 mac this thing got 165
frames per second so not only is the m1
pro 16 core graphics getting almost
double the performance it is using less
than half the energy meaning the battery
life is going to be much better speaking
of battery life keep in mind that we are
running that test i think at this point
before we get into the real world test
let me give you guys just a little
sample 64
on our 16-inch intel macbook pro and 82
on the m1 system but we are not going to
start really pushing it with real world
tests and now let's cover the thermal
performance heat and fan noise i have my
thermal camera out here and let's get a
baseline reading i have 30 degrees on
the new m1 pro 16 inch and if we look at
the keyboard the actual deck
it is fairly cool 27 now moving over to
the intel 16 inch we have that big hot
spot right there
and the top temp is also 31 here so not
a huge difference yet let's start with
our test and bam right away our intel
machine hits 50 watts 85 88 watts 89 oh
my goodness
90 watts of power usage and the m1 pro
unbind is only using
27.6 watts and that is staying at that
peak the intel mac hit 97 degrees and
then the fans kicked up and it lowered
the wattage in order to cool itself down
whereas the hottest portion of our m1
pro
mac is now sitting at 50 degrees celsius
that's actually the power supply
proximity the dice the hottest part is
at 46 degrees celsius compared to 96.
it's been three minutes so far and the
fans are basically at idle on this 16
inch they are silent and they're barely
spun up but one was literally shut off
right now but looking at the 16 inch
they are almost maxed out running at 4
800 rpm and slowly climbing and now they
are fully maxed out that is crazy and
going back to the 16-inch m1 pro look at
that we're right there at idle and then
here just a tiny bit literally what is
that 160 rpm over this machine
literally is silent i can't believe it's
doing a full cpu 100 workload for five
minutes now and it is just staying crazy
cool guys the inch ran cool but this 16
inch is on a whole nother level in case
you guys didn't know there are actually
vents here by the display that easily
let out hot air whereas the old design
it had to go to the back anyways because
this section was completely blocked and
that definitely helps you can actually
see it right there where the hot spots
are on that screen that's the hot air
coming out of there even the fans
basically at idle and the hottest spot
is that screen at 41
compared to the intel system wow 45
degrees right there definitely hotter
overall and of course with the 16 inch
running so cool we're still at the full
gigahertz whereas this one it did down
clock uh all the way down to 3.3 right
there um right now it's running at 3.39
all right we are done let's wait for the
intel model and i'll give you guys a
little tidbit this thing ran at 68 watts
most of the time until the end had to
slow down even more compared to compared
to a solid 27.5 for the m1 pro that
means that the intel is using two and a
half times more power just like the
graphics were our intel 16 inch scored 7
128 that's a pretty sad score compared
to even the m1 chip that sips power
and the 16 16-inch m1 pro chip scored 12
276 so we have 72 percent more
performance
while using two and a half times less
power and now let's see that performance
put into use for programming we are
going to run our x code benchmark shout
out to max miramenko for making this
benchmark for us and the terminal
command that makes it super easy to run
bam the code is now compiling our cpus
are fully maxed out and bam the intel is
finally done the fans are still blaring
whereas the m1 pro fans didn't even turn
on and what's our difference here well
we have
279.6 seconds basically 280 compared to
104
wow that is 2.7 times faster so for 3d
rendering in cinebench we saw 72 percent
here with optimizations with a unified
memory and all of that good stuff 2.7
times faster and completely silent that
is incredible and now let's go ahead and
test out logic pro just so you guys know
we're going to add in more tests with
each video that we're putting out so
make sure you guys stay tuned and here
we're going to start out with 80 tracks
we're going to see how much cpu usage
that we have and how much basically
tracks these computers can handle before
they overload and look at that over here
we're at 84
basically and here with the m1 pro we're
only at 43 oh we just got a system
overload of course we have frequency
spikes stuff like that so it looks like
the intel one couldn't even handle 80.
i'm gonna go ahead and restart that at
79 and here we're only 43
so how about we go up to
120
even 120 tracks is only 57
of the cpu man all right how about let's
enable all 140 here the intel crashed so
we're going to go down to 79 wow the
intel's hitting 100 degrees celsius
while doing this but hasn't overloaded
yet all right looks like the intel max
is out at 78 tracks
and our m1 just did 140 bam it crashed
with 160 so it's somewhere between there
and bam it just finished
155 so that means that it could do
almost double the amount of tracks in
logic compared to the previous i7 intel
16 inch macbook pro and now what about
photo editing i have lightroom opened up
right here in our next video we're
actually taking a look at affinity photo
but let's go ahead and switch through
these massive files
as far as speed they basically look to
be identical the faster ssd doesn't
really look to be helping in these
situations let's zoom into this 42
megapixel image
about the same on both and let's export
these 50 edited raw images to jpeg while
the m1 is already at like 60
compared to like 20 here and i'm
actually really excited to test out the
n1 max chip because it has that crazy
400 gigabyte per second bandwidth and
that definitely helps with lightroom so
we'll see that in the future but for now
it is almost done bam okay there we go
this one's not even halfway yet and bam
finally the intel mac is finished
this took three minutes and 47 seconds
for this 50 edited raw file export to
jpeg compared to
1 minute and 23 seconds that is
2.73 times faster almost three times
faster for and of course this is also
gonna go into effect if you're making
previews if you're doing hdr stuff it's
gonna have a massive difference so if
you're a photo editor and you use
lightroom this is gonna be such a
dramatic update for you and with that
finish before we do blender and final
cut i have to mention the battery life
because looking at the intel system we
are now at five percent battery we
unplugged both of these and uh four
hours and 20 minutes ago of course a lot
of the time we're taking the cases off
we were um you know looking at the
models themselves not really pushing
them to the limit other than maybe the
last hour or so and so we have five
percent here go ahead and take a guess
what the m1 pro 16-inch mac pro is at
battery life wise comment down below and
with that let me show you guys the new
16-inch is that 52
battery life
basically double the battery life of the
previous one and that isn't even
completely under heavy use i think if it
we were just doing benchmarks the whole
time none of the other stuff it probably
would be triple the battery life which
makes sense if the cpu and the gpu both
use two and a half times and then
obviously the fans have to spin up all
the time on this system all that stuff
so that is a crazy difference and now
it's time for the blender test you guys
have been asking about it so i have the
latest versions here and i downloaded
the party tug
sample project that's online you guys
could test this yourself i have it all
loaded up here let's go ahead and render
it on both wow the m1 was fast but the
intel is now done it took 43.43
seconds go ahead and just guess how long
this m1 took i can't believe this it
took
9 seconds 9.24
that is 4.7 times faster to render this
scene right here that's a crazy
difference way more than we saw in the
benchmarks guys if you use blender
my goodness this is a massive massive
update these real world results are way
bigger than those benchmarks and now
let's get into some video editing with
final cut in tomorrow's video we're
going to test out davinci resolve but
today we have multiple tests here i'm
going to start out with stabilizing this
one minute 4k clip now this uses
graphics to do this so let's go ahead
and click stabilize on both i'm going to
hit my timer bam the m1 got finished
waiting on the intel still going quick
final cut's so optimized bam all right
that was almost twice as fast we have
7.2 seconds compared to 13.8 yeah we got
to get into those little specifics
basically double the graphics
performance for rendering and analyzing
all those kind of stuff with final cut
now we are going to go ahead and do an
export and now i have some canon r5
footage this is 10 bit 422
you guys could see that on intel mac it
is stuttering like crazy
where with the m1 pro it's completely
smooth i have a lot on here the graphics
is at 72 cp is only at 17
fans are completely off it's playing
back amazingly well compared to that
stuttery mess now sony also allows you
to use this high-end codec that's very
good quality but very tough to work with
other brands are as well so you can see
the new m1s kill it with this now let's
go ahead and do an export test as well
and see how long it takes for a five
minute project
and bam both of them are done
this is a crazy difference the intel mac
took 12 minutes and 50 seconds whereas
the base m1 pro took exactly three
minutes
that is over four times faster and i
have something to tell you this m1 mac
was actually limited by the encoders the
gpu and cpu were we're not maxed out
it's just the h.264 encoders are at
their max so when we test out the m1 max
model has doubled encoders that will be
interesting and for our last test we
have some 4k prores raw that is graded
and this is actually very well optimized
for final cut it edits smoothly even on
the intel max before it's a very great
codec but then when you go to transcode
or when you're exporting it definitely
takes some time so let's take this five
minute project and we are gonna export
it all right guys this one is actually
limited by the gpu performance and i saw
how fast it was going on the bin 14 inch
this has a non-bin look that we're at 50
already compared to 9 on this intel
system bam we are finished on the m1 pro
and what's crazy is that this time the
pro res encoders that these m1s pros and
mac systems have in there uh it actually
wasn't the limitation it was the
graphics performance now it makes sense
why apple put in double the encoders in
the m1 max chip because it has twice the
graphics performance and these
performance
this is just crazy speed for anybody
that works with pro res or pro res raw
all right guys we hit 50
it took three minutes and 10 seconds
it's pretty linear i don't want to wait
any longer
so basically six minutes and 20 seconds
for this thing to export compared to one
minute and eight seconds
that is literally what like a six times
performance difference that is massive
and keep this in mind guys i continued
all those extra tests blender and
lightroom and this raw editing on
battery on the m1 pro and it just jumped
from 40 to 39 percent battery life while
this one we had to plug it in i don't
know it was an hour hour and a half ago
in our testing that is just crazy
battery life so what is the verdict well
i don't think we have ever seen this big
of an upgrade in one year and if you're
somebody that just bought a 16-inch
intel version a year ago or a month ago
or a week ago before this came out guys
i'm sorry because
this is such a massive difference no
matter what you're doing not only do we
have the better speakers we have the
better webcam the crazy display for hdr
that's a huge upgrade the battery life
my goodness pretty much three times as
good if you're pushing it
massive massive differences and then of
course we have the performance
difference where we're somewhere between
60 all the way to six times the
performance depending on what you do
these are just insane machines and this
is only the base 16 inch keep that in
mind we are going to also test davinci
resolve and other tests in tomorrow's
video and that one we're going to go
against the high-end i9 system that has
the 5600m graphics that's like a 800
upgrade compared to the m1 max as 32
core graphics both 32 gigs of ram that's
gonna be a killer video and with that
guys if you made it this far
if you haven't yet picked up one of
these um m1 pro max shirts with a little
cross off the sharpie edition this is
limited time this is going to go away at
the end of this week so you guys can use
the promo code m1 pro to get 20 off if
you guys want to support us with that we
also launched short channels youtube
shorts instagram reels and tick tock if
you guys want to see little clips before
stuff gets posted make sure to follow us
on there and you guys can click the
subscribe button above and comment below
for a chance to win a 2500
m1 pro macbook thank you guys for
watching check out one of those great
videos right there this is max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]